the Karman line is the point at which
the Earth's atmosphere ends in outer
space begins the Karman line is at 62
miles above sea level and any distance
from sea level at the Karman line or
above is considered outer space set C
equals 62 and use X to represent
distance from sea level write an
inequality in terms of X and C that
represents the distances from sea level
that are inside or its atmosphere so we
want to write an inequality in terms of
X and C and X is the distance above sea
level and C is the Karman line and we
want to think about things we want to
think about distances that are inside
Earth's atmosphere so that's going to be
anything that's below the Karman line
and so let's see I would write X is less
than C because they're telling a C is 62
now I want to make sure so they say the
carbon line is the point at which the
Earth's atmosphere ends and outer space
begins so what if we're right at 62
miles the common line is 62 miles above
sea level and any distance from sea
level at the Karman line or above is
considered outer space okay so if I'm at
sea or above I'm in outer space so only
the things that are not material are
strictly below C so I'm going to do a
less than not a less than or equal sign
right over here all right got it right
let's do another one a black hole is a
region of space where the pull of
gravity is so strong that nothing can
get back out once it is fallen inside
let's use e to represent the largest
distance from the center of the black
hole that pulls objects inside if X
represents the distance of an object
from the center of the black hole write
an inequality for safe distances from
the center of the black hole in terms of
X and E so X is the distance from the
center e represents the largest distance
from the center of the black hole that
pulls objects inside so if you're at E
away or close you're going to be pulled
inside but we want to think about safe
distances so if your
further away then II you should be cool
and it's strictly greater than because
if you're at E that's the largest
distance that you would still be pulled
inside very good